welcome back to new rockstars deadpool 3
is
officially confirmed to be coming to the
marvel cinematic universe ryan reynolds
wade wilson the merc with the mouth
joining kevin feige's avengers toy box
now we got a toy from romantics in that
mix
i'm eric boss this is rogue theory the
show that brings you the wildest nerdy
hot takes and the topics you can't stop
talking about for those of you not from
l.a romantics is an adult accessory
store
because often i do have to explain my
jokes because they suck
with me to go rogue today
is a panel that i love starting with
writer comedian and
a long time friend of mine long time
fellow eric
erica lusu welcome back man hey man i
can't wait to go back to romantics with
you
don't tell them i needed a friend i
didn't know i didn't know what to do
eric stick together literally that's
right that's right also joining us
returning guest tom michelson hey man
welcome back hey
how's it going everybody uh just want to
say a big shout out to everybody who
said i look like
kingpin and hitman last time i was on
here thanks for the halloween ideas i
know what to do next year so thank you
didn't recognize you outside your keanu
uh john
i'm also happy to welcome to new rock
stars from rooster teeth co-host on a
panel i was on uh not too long ago
thankfully did not call out how little
about gaming i know
fellow nerd enthusiast of all things
nerdy
kayla milton welcome kayla hi thanks for
having me uh we didn't call you out on
how little you knew about gaming but
this is going to call me
on how little i know about marvel i will
return the favor you're in good hands
here and based off of some of the
theories i have spouted on this channel
before
you aren't gonna tell the difference
there are times where i look like i have
no idea what i'm talking about
as well we're good this is gonna be fun
all right uh big news this week uh a lot
of big news but some news came out that
deadpool 3 is coming to the mcu this
wasn't a certain thing
we weren't sure what form it was going
to take whether ryan reynolds is going
to be part of it whether it's me r
rated well we now know that bob's
burgers writers the
molyneux sisters have been hired to
write a script for deadpool 3.
this will be the first deadpool movie
produced by marvel studios and kevin
feige
so that means he's going to be crossing
the streams
hopefully not his streams with uh with
other avengers and mcu
heroes and villains siri star ryan
reynolds is still set to star in the
film and it's supposedly going to be
r rated which is a first for a disney
produced marvel movie
but we'll see where that goes uh i don't
know if they're going to be able to
commit to an rated film
if it's still going to be that connected
to the mcu but i wanna know
from all of you how is an r-rated
deadpool movie gonna fit
into the mcu as we know it going forward
what is this movie gonna be
why don't we start with you all right
well i cannot wait for this
hopeful deadpool 3 disney movie to come
out
produced and made by the mouse himself
mickey mouse disney enterprises
i think this one is going to be an
r-rated romp for the whole family
that's over 18 years old
i think that this is going to be a film
where wade wilson saves the world
yet again but this time it starts off
with him being given a secret
mercenary mission he gets hired by a
shadowy figure
to take out a specific mark and that
mark
is professor charles xavier he's being
tested
killing professor x and that's how we
introduce him and collide worlds with
him and the x-men for real this time not
just colossus
so he goes to war with the x-men trying
to kill
beloved professor x and in their scuffle
they find out that they have the same
villain
and we find out that the person that
paid or is going to pay
uh deadpool to kill professor x is none
other than the intergalactic tv
personality mojo i don't know if you
guys remember
mojo that big gross yellow dude
so he's pulling the strings that's how
marvel is and disney are going to
introduce mojo into this thing so more
intergalactic
interplanetary drama so mojo's mission
is he wants to take over the earth and
make that the new set of a new
intergalactic reality tv show
and he knows that if professor x is
still around he can use his mind powers
to keep
all the humans and other beings on earth
from being taken over mentally
by mojo to go along as puppets for this
intergalactic you know reality tv show
that mojo's trying to do
so deadpool the x-men professor x they
beat mojo
and everything's great and wraps up with
a nice little bun
uh and then i gotta see what my ending
wait this was written hold on
oh no don't tell the people at home okay
that's what happens okay it's cool so
after deadpool and the x-men defeat mojo
in an epic battle
blood and guts everywhere it's r-rated
it's beautiful cgi
top-notch this is what happens
everything's cool the earth is saved but
they find out that now that mojo is gone
it kind of left the door open for one of
mojo's favorite puppets
in the universe the silver surfer the
solar surfer is gonna skate into the
disney marvel mcu and that's gonna set
up the scene for
the next marvel movie to come out in
phase four or five
whoa whoa this movie's
crazy this is like the the pitch you go
into the pitch meeting with me and like
this is what my movie will be if you
want to meet me halfway i guess i'm okay
with it but really that
that halfway movie people would be like
whoa he was able to get all that into
marvel movies
i think obviously my favorite thing
about this is that in this
movie uh professor charles xavier is
essentially every
marvel mutant agent who's like no you
cannot take this gig
this isn't right for you so i'm going to
force you not to take this job just go
back take a couple more
workshops for the next six months we'll
skip this pilot season and then
then we'll see what his programming
slate is next year
i want to know from you what do you have
any fan casting in mind who do you want
to see as professor x who
who do you want to see as mojo well mojo
either has to be
danny devito yeah yeah
or fat suit jared leto it has to be
either though
he would just gain the weight he would
spend
charles xavier right i think he needs to
be our first choice for all these guys
eddie murphy nutty professional
situation he's gonna play like six
characters
danny devito would be perfect i know a
lot of uh new rockstars fans want tommy
to play mojo he is our mojo
here uh for sure for sure but danny
devito i think yeah you gotta get to be
doing it if davido's not
uh too busy with the next season of
sunny we'll throw tommy yeah yeah
yeah sure uh absolutely all right oh so
that was a
pretty pretty grog theory so you're
gonna come out of the gate strong with
three points i'm warding you three
points
uh yeah thanks man and my three points
have materialized into
winter batman dick wool socks
holiday these spiderman footies you know
because it's
a chilly 60 degrees in l.a right now oh
yeah
and this nifty uh black panther guide
thanks
some good some good merch there all
right very nice very nice
all right uh next up kayla i want to
hear from you what is this deadpool 3
movie gonna be
how is it going to connect with the mcu
we know so far i have seen the first two
deadpool movies and i think that they
were fantastic
but i think in deadpool 3 uh he's going
to
fully like breaking the fourth wall go
into acknowledging that he is in fact a
part of the disney universe now
and in in doing that he will try to find
his way to the correct spider-man so
he's going to spend the entire time like
on the romantic journey to try and find
tom holland
but along the way he meets all of the
wrong spiderman so i'm talking about
cameos from andrew garfield
toby mcguire that one animated uh
spider-man series that was on disney xd
where he was voiced by drake bell
and then like yeah and then like he
finally like
near the end he gets to meet up with uh
tom holland
spider-man but then he realizes that
he's not allowed to say like the f-word
anymore
like he can't say [ __ ] anymore uh and
he's like
well clearly this isn't the universe for
me and he just kind of bounces back to
his like
in between time what i'm saying is i
want the entire movie to be
so broken through the through the fourth
wall that it just
doesn't feel like you're watching a
movie at all to the point where you're
like
is this just the ramblings of ryan
reynolds
[Laughter]
yes yes that is exactly
the deadpool movie i want like of course
it has to i feel like that's the only
way it works because
i think at the end of the day the allens
are gonna be like i was not in that
meeting the r-rated meeting we're gonna
do a pg-13 movie
i'm sorry and then that's how we're
gonna get around it he's gonna be he's
like
why am i being censored this is annoying
yeah that'd be awesome that is like the
perfect deadpool movie and yeah i think
you could argue the first deadpool was
just like
90 plus minutes of ryan reynolds just
kind of like
making jokes at you and making fun of
other superhero movies and
this is the way you bring them in yeah i
feel like the first wonderful movie
especially
was just ryan reynolds being like i've
read the source material
[Laughter]
i'm well versed in this genre
i'm not i'm not just an actor i'm also a
fan
yeah for sure i do want to see kind of a
a wild meta you know who framed roger
rabbit type thing
talking to the camera more of that more
of that because that's gonna be the
weirdest adjustment it's not the r-rated
stuff
it's not the violence so much it's not
the
the humor it's like the fact that he can
break that fourth wall
no other character does that in the mcu
and i think that's gonna be the weirdest
adjustment if you lean into that you can
rate it whatever you want
exactly and then i feel like as proof of
my concept
uh there was that rumor swirling around
a couple weeks ago
about uh toby maguire and andrew
garfield being like signed
for a movie and everyone assumed it was
the third spider-man movie but maybe
it's the third deadpool movie
yeah hell yeah why not yeah we don't
know we don't even know if it was true
or not but
until it's confirmed it can be whatever
marvel movie we want it to be
great theory this is like uh exactly the
kind of deadpool movie i want to see so
i'm awarding you three points as well
yes well done and you don't have to
convert it to anything it could just be
three points that you hold in your heart
i mean
if i had to convert it i guess i could
convert it into
uh this guitar pick i've been holding
the whole time
uh this hand sanitizer that also happens
to be green
and this sticker that says don't talk to
me until i've had my vibe check
that's great this whole conversion thing
is throwing me because like it started
as like
we used to do this in person we had
awesome little blocks that was like
visible points
and then we went to quarantine mode and
now like we
we tried to put them in towards the
camera and that was going to run through
like a weird 3d facts or
and now it's like i can't even find the
sparkle box that i used
so it's just same points and now you're
just showing up stuff on your end and
people watching this for the first time
we're like
the hell are they doing
but we're doing it we're sticking to
this game all right two great theories
so far
tom it is your turn bring us home what's
deadpool gonna do to get in this
universe so
we know that you know marvel phase four
is going to blow the doors of the mcu
wide open with doctor strange the
multiverse of madness and we've even
you know got some confirmation that
strange is gonna even be in the next
spider-man something home sequel
right and that will plant seeds for a
future
even spider-verse team up so my theory
is as the worlds
of the multiverse collide the deadpool 3
will be about
wade getting sucked into the mcu from
the fox
marvel movie universe okay then using
his trusty time machine that we saw at
the end of uh deadpool 2.
we'll end up visiting all the best and
worst moments of the mcu like a greatest
hits album
i'm already imagining them retconning
some of our favorite scenes like maybe
he's trying to catch a flight in germany
and then civil war is happening outside
or maybe you know he's the one who
convinced taser face that that wasn't
even a good name
there's so many things you could do and
as we know kevin feige is a huge fan of
this show and he's watching right now
so um i already got some titles for him
okay i already got some titles for you
kevin ready uh the first one
is um deadpool 3 now that's what i call
marvel phase five
the second one which i think is the one
that you should go with kevin
deadpool three the fantabulous
emancipation of the one wade wilson from
the 20th century fox universe
[Laughter]
it's so good yeah that's perfect and you
know
that works because like harley quinn is
essentially what dc cinematic was trying
to do they're trying to have their
deadpool
and i think that element of it worked um
other things maybe not so much
but uh but hey hey uh that is such a fun
idea and
what you are kind of pitching here it
sounds like tom is like uh
what i kind of wanted the time heist to
be an avengers end game
like they it did start to feel like a
greatest hits album but
uh after that second act ended it's like
okay well i'm glad they revisited these
moments but i feel like this is the
greatest hits
that left out like you know 70 of the
discography of my favorite band
and they were even like logically they
could have gone to the collector's vault
and gotten two stones in one go and
you know these are things where it's
just like the writers say that they
spent months and months thinking about
this but did they if they missed that
one
anyway i i have gripes uh but what you
are pitching
sounds like the way they can show part
two of that greatest hits like
what i'm imagining you know there's the
the toby maguire meme of they re-edit
him
in the scenes where he's like running
through the avengers team
yeah dude uh that could be exactly what
uh because you know so much of like ryan
reynolds deadpool was a parody of toby
maguire spider-man
yeah this it sounds awesome and i would
totally love to see this movie i didn't
even realize that i wanted to see this
movie until you pitched the fact that
you had
titles locked ready to go man you were
ready
four four points what four points oh my
gosh
all right so let's see i'm gonna convert
those to three of these uh push pins
that i have on my desk
and oh no this is this one i kind of
this little uh gladiator
hulk bobble head that's great yeah
that's awesome does it have the sick
fade he had in the movie
yeah he has his little helmet mohawk
so that's pretty cool yeah yeah it
bobbles a little bit
uh all right we had three amazing
deadpool theories i want to hear from
all of you watching especially you kevin
feige down below
if you kind of haven't biking we will
pin your comment just that's all you
to do just comment our videos just first
first and we'll
pin it yeah like uh i i don't know how
much money they spent to make this
happen uh but i'm glad
disney and marvel are doing this and
wade wilson
ryan reynolds deadpool is really the
best thing to come out of those later
years x-men movies over at fox
so get him in a movie as quickly as you
can
so happy to see this happening hey eric
you have a quick question
what would be your number one moment
that he would go back to in his time
machine from the marvel
cinematic universe all the phases i want
him to go back
to the time heist and watching tony
stark watching tony stark he's behind it
like another layer i want him to salute
captain america's ass
as cap is saluting his other ass i want
him to go
one layer deeper on all of those things
the deleted scene where thor in asgard
is drunk and peeing over the ledge i
want deadpool to get pissed off
there's so many opportunities for them
to insert him and even
i hope they even do like some of the
worst moments like things that we can't
stand like they'll be
i don't know like what you want to pick
from like thor too or other things that
people think are like have them talk to
like even edward norton for like a
second be like wait aren't you and he's
like you never mind you know like
yeah look like mark ruffalo yeah exactly
you can do so many good things where
marvel could just you know take a
take a jab at themselves and everything
yeah he'd be perfect to kind of go back
like
wait a minute terence howard yeah
yeah exactly exactly you don't look like
terry
you look a little different all right uh
before we continue some other
marvel breaking news i want to do a
quick shout out you'll notice i'm
wearing our custom
this is the way shirt this came straight
out of new rockstar's merch store
at newrockstarsmerch.com uh this is a
limited amount that's
we're really just doing in celebration
of uh the mandalorian season two
we're gonna run out at some point and
they're going back in the vault uh we're
not gonna just keep selling these
why because we have like new designs
that are gonna be coming out we're gonna
do like on rotation uh you gotta get
like the seasonal
thing and we got so many great items
check this out um
hats shirts hoodies masks i got uh hi
i'm eric voss shirt um so you know
uh you can wear my name on you if you
want
and you can be eric boss oh and uh yeah
we got some new designs that we're very
very excited about you're gonna want to
jump on this
it's really a great gift item for
someone who watches the show
i like to look at these as like the hot
topic designs that i wish hot topic had
uh but they don't because you know they
aren't
made by nerds they're just made by
people like i think this will sell
uh whereas we got nerds uh locked away
uh who are making these designs and if
they make good designs they'll be
uh paid um it's it's us it's awesome
doing these
anyway uh neuroxmerch.com jump on that
also we want to give a quick shout out
to our patron ruby
who won this week's rogue theory on
discord that contest we do every week on
our patreon only discord server their
pitch
for the potential plot of black panther
2 that is now going into production this
summer
had uh namor in atlantis and a new
wakanda with the black panther mantle
and shuri discovering mutant jeans
that sounds like a lot of crazy fun
stuff to happen in the movie
to submit your own speculation and to
support this channel you can become a
patron by going to patreon.com new
rockstars
all right um kayla
if that cat wants to stay in frame you
let
that kid get started i'm worried about
him bumping he likes to rub up on the
mic when i'm on calls
and i i knew he's gonna do it that's
like
shifting him back to the bed apollo
wants to be a
youtube star oh he loves the camera
anytime i'm talking like
any time i'm talking at the glowing box
he's like oh what's what's this
all right let's uh let's dive into
everything new we've learned about the
miss
marvel series coming out on disney plus
we just got some
photos from the set as they are
beginning shooting we're learning a lot
about the co-stars that are being cast
and we get our first look at iman valani
as
miss marvel herself kamala khan it's no
it's kamala khan
i'm saying kamala because
yeah yeah so uh in the comics uh kamala
khan's powers are connected to
actually you can kind of say they're
connected to the eternals all things are
connected to the eternals but
uh it's really to the inhumans uh
there's a terrigen mist
that comes in and she uh inhales that
target mist she cocoons up
in her cocoon she has a vision of her
stan avengers captain marvel and tony
stark and cap and
in these photos this is like a homemade
costume for uh captain marvel
um and yeah she is a younger character
so we might see her maybe set up in a
future young avengers group as we've
seen other kind of young avengers
maybe being set up in marvel phase four
i wanna hear from you guys
uh pitch me how miss marvel will make
her big entrance into the mcu what is
her
what is her role gonna be in this new
avengers lineup going forward
and tom since you did uh the last one
last time why don't you go first this
time
so um you know with with the failure of
the inhumans kind of gaining any real
traction like with that abc show and now
with agents of shield being
kind of considered an ultimate alternate
timeline now um
my pitch is uh will set the stage for
ms marvel to help influence the future
of marvel movies and shows because
as we know um kevin feig and company
they don't they don't mind changing
things uh you know they've already shown
that they've changed a bunch of
character origins so i think that ms
marvel's origin is gonna be changed a
little bit you know but like marvel's
already changed
iron patriots to become roadie um yeah
ego is star-lord's father in the movies
and
of course the mandarin which yay if you
like and i know right if you don't like
um so my theory is that she won't be
getting her powers from the terrigen
mist
she's gonna instead be a mutant
oh okay i think that because we already
know the x-men are coming they're like
the biggest property that
they've acquired from fox so making her
a mutant gives marvel the chance to
set the stage for what the x-men can be
like in this new universe and plus she's
the perfect age
for when the mutant powers would be
hitting you know with puberty and all
and one more retcon worth mentioning
here is that scarlet witch isn't even a
mutant in the mcu so if scarlet witch
can't be
a mutant then marvel owes us a mutant
with kamalaka
right either either like retconned
uh wanda maximoff to be a mutant and say
like we just called her enhanced in that
one scene because we didn't get the
legal rights deadpool can give that
explanation but right right
uh uh so long uh what will your miss
marvel's powers be does she still get
the
the big fist yeah yeah no she's still in
vegan she'll still
um have all of that it just it just
won't be from the
territory i think you'd have to spend a
lot of time building that and explaining
that and
whereas you know if she's kind of wakes
up one day with these powers and
we start planting he's like you're
hearing the word mutant here i think
that'd be a lot easier for them to
just get on with the show instead of
trying to build this this
this the mcu version of what the
inhumans would be
since yeah i guess technically they
haven't done it yet
yeah yeah there was yeah the inhuman
show there were inhumans and agents of
shields
there was everything with quake you know
she got the territory she cocooned up
but uh
yeah i i think you're right tom i think
that is kind of the direction they would
go
when you think of miss marvel other than
people who you know die hard read ms
marvel comics i don't think they need to
say first and foremost she is an inhuman
no she's like you know a pakistani
american kid
who loves the avengers and then she gets
to kind of become a protege
of captain marvel that's kind of what
they associate her with so yeah if they
were to make her meet and i don't think
anyone would bat an eye really
meanwhile people in the comics are like
the hell how
dare you yeah this guy unsub unsub
tom uh for your theory i'm going to
award you two points
yeah two points sorry i'm out of things
to convert but
i still got this totally fine you still
got that convert the storm breaker over
there
okay great kayla it is your turn i want
to hear from you
uh what do you think miss marvel is
gonna look like in the mcu what is what
is her role going to be how is she going
to be introduced
okay so again this is an all throws
theory because i'm doing the best that i
can with the knowledge that i have
i am a huge fan of the runaway series uh
sure yeah i feel like i'm one of
probably 10 people who watched the hulu
series that got cancelled
either late last year earlier this year
but
uh what i feel like is because it's
going to be a series and not a movie
that maybe it will be some sort of
redemption arc for the runaways and she
will be
introduced via a crossover event where
they are all
like high schoolers who are all dealing
with their own thing
and she's like trying to figure out like
how her powers work and she's just like
oh there's like these tales of these
kids that live in the mountains and they
all have powers and maybe they like
hang out and like do stuff but then
obviously the with the runaway is having
their main members ending up being
villains like he maybe he'll become like
the villain that gets her to like
finally take over her own powers and i
feel like that would just be
really cool and fun and it could also be
a fun way
to uh bring back the uh scroll shout out
from the captain marvel movie because my
favorite character
they're like a shape-shifting scroll and
they're like married to
one of the one of the kids in the
runaways and i feel like having that
character
uh just be shown on screen would bring
me a lot of joy uh but
also just as part of like the oh you can
kind of shapeshift too i feel like they
have a really fun friendship
dynamic also i just really like uh teen
dramas not
like a the archie comics one but more
like a fun not riverdale yeah not
riverdale
uh more of a mystery gang
and i scooby-doo think that would be
really fun and like you know
pg-13 enough for disney plus you bring
up a good point because i think tonally
uh things like runaways will kind of be
what things like miss marvel look like
clearly
disney plus and marvel studios are
looking to branch out
tonally and genre-wise from what we
know to be like the avengers movies
right yeah and you know this started
with things like doctor strange and
black panther and we're seeing it now
with like a black widow
really you could say it started with
like captain america winter soldier when
they did like a spy drama kind of thing
or when thor was this weird as guardian
royal drama they they
want to every once and all try to make
something that doesn't you know everyone
if you were to ask a
casual watcher marvel movies they're
like yeah i saw either age of ultron
or uh civil war i don't remember what
the scene was in that one or the other
well now you're just quoting me from the
rtx panel
i think that's exactly what i said hey i
mean uh even like a couple years into
doing this job
obsessively re-watching these marvel
movies there are scenes where i'm like
wait wait wait did that scene happen in
the age of ultron or did that happen in
captain america winter soldier i can't
remember if this particular shot of cap
is in that movie or that movie yeah it's
the seamless storytelling so you just
like
it's all just one epic yarn in your
brain pretty much and that you know by
the time end game came out it's like oh
that's it paid
off but going ahead and phase four i i
do think things like
it's gonna feel like runaways sometimes
it's gonna feel like these teen dramas
and miss marvel's gonna be that thing it
may not be
geared toward dudes in their early 40s
who
love references to things he grew up
reading
miss marvel is a recent it's like a 2013
comic she didn't exist before that so
it's going to be geared towards
younger audiences and uh yeah and i
think if it were to be something like
runaways
through a literal crossover of things
like squirrels or like the dark hole
you know you know there's all kinds of
stuff that happened in runaways that i'd
love to see there's a whole mess of
stuff that happens in the runaways that
could easily
be in i mean i maybe i'm just telling
myself that because i want it so bad but
i think it's possible for sure um i'm
also going to
award you two points for your theory i
will convert those
into a pin that says what's your moon
sign
and uh these bravery band-aids
what are bravery band-aids oh that's
nice oh my god they say stuff like
didn't cry and i've had worse
yeah they kind of look like like medals
of honor
those are the things i say after i eat
taco bell
people cry the worst
but also probably what's your moon sign
so
all right awusu uh it is your turn what
do you think uh miss marvel's gonna look
like
in the mcu i like miss marvel a lot i
think miss marvel was going to
uh like my other copano said look like a
nice team
like fun drama very tonally different
from a thor the dark world or you know
captain america first avenger
uh i think the origin story is going to
be that kamala
khan is an enhanced individual
via infinity stone i think what's going
to happen
is since her parents are uh pakistani
immigrants
uh one of them is a scientist that works
at avengers tower says she grows up in
new jersey that's where
kamala lives one of her parents goes
into the city to go to work you know
bridge and tunnel folks
somehow accidentally through a fun
mistake an infused
object that's infused with infinity
stone powers
ends up on her parents person and the
parent goes home
commonly gets a hold of him accidentally
and it envelops her
in infinity stone power residue
and that's what triggers something in
her genome to
give her new powers and give her her
elasticity
and also have different versions of her
from the multiverse
converge to give her her powers because
that's kind of a thing that happens
in comic books yeah she's accessing like
uh alternate versions of herself
when she's powering up yeah yes that's
right so we'll have that
yeah so we'll have that connect with the
multiverse of madness stuff happening
that the mcu is clearly going towards
and that's how she develops her powers
and so the whole movie will be a
coming-of-age tale
with her figuring out her superpowers
how to handle her powers
her going through puberty and then also
figuring how to balance
being a a good daughter and a good
teenager
with being a good superhero in in the
vein of her one of her favorite
superheroes captain marvel
and so as she battles evil doers in her
native new jersey
uh she'll overcome the big drama and
challenges
and then i think at the end her big
main villain will be captain marvel
in a reimagined civil war 2 storyline
that the mcu will delve into
with captain marvel doing battle against
other avengers
for the sake of the future and there's a
bunch of future stuff that goes on in
civil war 2 in the comic books but
that's my theory for miss marvel whoa
we were on a two-point um
scale right there and then you dropped
in that and then and i'm like
well you bury the lead my friend um so
i have questions um well first off i do
love this idea of
her powers coming from infinity stone
radiation because it is essentially what
powered up carol danvers right you know
it came from the tesseract which powered
the
the light speed engine which spilled her
i guess
like exploded she's like i have these
powers now
uh and i think if something similar
happens with kamala khan that that'd be
cool to see that kind of parallelism
but i gotta know what is the dividing
thing in this civil war two because i
want to see a civil war too
i think there's a lot of uh reasons is
it like skrulls or something that you
know
a secret invasion thing that triggers a
civil war what's the fight over i think
it could be involving the scroll and
it's a
secret wars invasions but then also in
the comic book
the whole thing that split tony stark
and captain marvel
was how they wanted to handle crime and
villain
villain activity because um i think a
mutant from the multiverse comes in who
can tell the future
it can tell them when someone's going to
do something bad i think
the future seeing mutants said that
miles morales was going to kill
captain america so he they had to jail
miles morales and then tony stark was
like no
people have free will we gotta let
things play out and then captain marvel
was like
no that we gotta go get boss morales
right now
so i think not exactly that will happen
but
since we have seen time travel in the
mcu with the events of the infinity saga
um i think some sort of future dictating
what marvel superheroes or villains will
do
what mischief will inform carol danvers
aka captain marvel
to be like we have to go get this person
we have to go apprehend this other
person
and then that will cause a rift much
like the events in the
mcu movie civil war caused a rift
between iron man and captain america
over signing the sokovia accord and
turning themselves over to the
government
oh so that's a very good point the
sokovia accord's debate was never
settled
they just it got more personal when you
know tony found out that
uh winter soldier killed his parents and
then that's what it was over but then
no one talked for two years and then
thanos came and that's what brought them
together
that debate that you know tag is still
open uh
and people need to finish that argument
um so if that ends up evolving into
something like
true superhero registration like we saw
in the civil war comics that's the whole
debate
i think that's a fascinating debate that
needs to happen in the mcu
like do we have to register these these
folks
does that lead to preemptive
imprisonment um is it that kind of
slippery slope and
you're having someone who can kind of
foresee the future that that's a
fascinating debate that's kind of like
the minority report
thought crime kind of thing they're not
thought crime that's a different thing
whatever
i'm mixing orwell with philippe dick i
don't give up
okay but uh elusu a great theory the
fact that when i asked you
for follow-up you met me with time
travel you've earned that third point so
you get three points
oh thanks man well i went into the
future to see that you would like that
point you know
obviously yeah i knew i knew i'm sorry
okay cool so from my three
new points i've materialized those into
a deck of ace playing cards
uh cocoa butter can stay ashy in this
cold weather
and uh these uh surgical sterile gloves
because 20 20 why not
hell yeah yeah you're still gonna need
those
definitely any of those all right it's
still pretty even i think uh we're at
tom in usu with six kayla at five
but you can even up the score with our
rogue
questions is everyone ready yeah all
right here we go first question william
sonoma has released some electric blue
macaroons or macrons
macarons as a whichever they are people
yelled at me because they said mech
roots
as a tie-in with the most recent episode
of the mandalorian these
pastries cost fifty dollars for a packet
of twelve
what could make a packet of cookies
worth fifty dollars to you
uh it depends on uh if you look at the
nutrition facts what's the m
count i need to know how many
midichlorians there are in this
case if i eat them i better be getting
access to the force that's all i'm
saying for 50 bucks
i better be able to lift something
doesn't have to be an x-wing
like at least my drink you know flowing
over here like oh like
that i better get something for 50 bucks
i better get some midi chlorine so for
me it's the m count
it's fair that's fair that's right okay
so i feel like the go-to
obvious answer would be like oh it's
gotta have the blue milk in it ha ha
no i want i want the crust to be made
out of ground up blue kyber crystals
that is the only way i would pay
uh fifty dollars for only total backers
it just tears up your stomach yeah oh it
absolutely destroys you but
i i feel like you'd be like oh that's a
that's the spicy macaroon as you're
eating it
every time you go to the bathroom the
death star fires
they're like an alderaan just gets extra
toilet just
becomes alderaan downstairs neighbors
just like salt bay the kyber crystals on
top like it's just yeah
oh yes i
winced when i saw that these cost as
much as they do
it's travesty in this economy so i think
that when you eat these
macrons uh and you poop them out
they glow blue like luke skywalker's
lightsaber
that's their they've got that energy of
the force in them
and after you've eaten them for a whole
day
anytime you burp your stomach also
follows that up with
this is the way
[Music]
[Laughter]
god all three of those well worth the
money and uh
you know i feel like they have invented
bioluminescent stuff
that is non-toxic i bet they could make
like [ __ ] that glows
are they right like the burger king
whopper a couple years ago that was
making everybody's poop black
they can make bioluminescent die i then
for sure my point goes
to owusu on that i'm sorry the the
to both parts of the the glowing stuff
and the burp
it's that's great all right and we have
one final question with black friday
just a few days away a child safety
watchdog group has named a toy dark
saber from the mandalorian
and a black panther glove with a
retractable claws two of the most
dangerous toys this holiday season
nerds pitch what imaginary nerd toy has
the potential
to be even more dangerous than those
parents just don't understand
uh how fun these toys can be so
i think a toy that could be two toys
that could be more dangerous than that
are an actual fully functioning
mandalorian jet pack i think that would
be way more fun
and way more dangerous and i think
that a demon bear tornado toy from the
new mutants
could be it just is more dangerous but
it serves as a vacuum and it's made by
dyson
[Laughter]
man a jet pack i think someone's already
invented that there's that dude flying
around lax
he's out there that's right if you zoom
in way close and enhanced he's got a
mandalorian armor on him
for mine i think this one is a dangerous
toy but also could be pretty useful i
could use one
i think they should make an actual
working me seeks box from rick and morty
i need that so bad like mr meeseeks go
to the store for me i don't want to get
the corona mr meeseeks when things open
up go to the gym for me i need to get
my workout today that would be so useful
exactly we can do and
and that would be dangerous because some
people would take advantage you know
like jerry did with this golf game so
that
yeah it's so useful but i think it's a
little bit too powerful in the wrong
oh for sure yeah yeah well for me
i was thinking it's a batman toy but
what the toy does
is it does orphan you so that can be
dangerous for your parents but then a
rich billionaire not jeff bezos a
different one
does come and adopt you and take you on
as his ward and i think that is a very
fun
educational experience for any kid out
there that wants
to switch it up and maybe become a
superhero this holiday season
but um it might be a little bit more
dangerous than those retractable black
panther gloves
oh just a bit yeah i love it it's the
robin maker
the robin baker oh i love it it won't
kill your sibling it will
only kill your parents well you can't
kill your sibling because then you have
to then we're like right kind of get
into like batwoman territory they have
to have a chance to become a villain too
so like
you need siblings for that yeah uh caleb
that is so
specific i'm giving you the point on
that one
but if my math serves me correct i think
that makes our winner this episode erica
wusu
congratulations do you have a wish you
would like to
request that we can deliver on i wish
for
everyone to have a happy turkey day even
people who aren't american and don't
celebrate it you must eat turkey
according to the fine print on a woosu's
wish
or have some chicken shaped peeps at
least yes other than other a turkey will
physically manifest in your home whether
you want it to or not
yeah you got to take care of it it's
like an egg in home egg
hopefully no death star action in the
bathroom after everyone's turkey day
let's avoid that please
[Laughter]
this has been such a fun episode of
rogue theory
thank you to all of our guests our
winner erica wusu
as well as tom michelson and kayla
milton thank you to all three of you
you've been
these have been some amazing theories i
would love to see all these movies
tv shows that you've pitched hopefully
uh one of you or all of you will get
hired to produce or write one of these
shows so we can say it all started right
here because we know feige watches
hey feige hey buddy for those of you
watching thank you so much for watching
or listening if you're uh getting this
to be a podcast if you do get a video
podcast
do us a favor leave us a nice rating and
review if you don't already just go
ahead and subscribe there just so you
know we get the numbers
that'd be great and uh you can follow me
at eavos on instagram twitter with
social media that i am on still
uh and you can subscribe here on new
rockstars on youtube
and so you can stay tuned to this and
other shows hit that notification bell
and uh we will see you
next time thanks everyone and uh have a
a safe
and healthy and wonderful holiday bye
[Music]
you